[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient
parler sport l'émission qu'il ne faut
absolument pas manquer si vous êtes un
amoureux du sport local pour
m'accompagner aujourd'hui une véritable
dream team ils sont quatre autour de
cette table avec moi présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite il est
toujours présent dans cette émission on
pourrait le remettre des bons points
chaque enregistrement tellement il donne
le meilleur de lui même à chaque instant
le capitaine hayettes dujarrier pistard
au club de vélizy 78 est avec nous oui
bonjour michael quand allez-vous très
très bien on va finir par croire que
j'ai que ça à faire abbas veut bien vous
voir en tout cas vous avez cravacher
aujourd'hui ans pour venir
ah oui c'est l'organisation était un peu
plus un peu plus chargé aujourd'hui
c'est un peu compliqué vous êtes le
principal
on passe de l'autre côté musique qui
nous vient tout droit de verser toujours
prêt à dégainer à la moindre occasion il
sera redoutable chroniqueur pendant une
heure et je n'en doute pas une seule
seconde le gladiateur pierre chevallier
du rugby-club de versailles et savez
celui qu'a et salut a tous formés
bonheur pierre chevalier comment allez
vous gérer ans je suis en pleine forme
on va parler d'actualité qui est plutôt
florissante en ce moment pour les sports
qui m'intéresse c'est les clubs qui
m'intéressent donc plein fouet n'en dit
pas trouvera jeu d'erreurs dans quelques
instants
on passe de l'autre côté musique c'est
une véritable légende de cette émission
et il nous gratifie encore une nouvelle
fois de sa présence ses paroles sont
plus attendue que celle d'un gandhi ou
d'un barack obama le mythe genre milices
ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
bonjour gens beaux jours mickaël bonjour
à tous et bien parfait très bien merci
merci cet accueil chaleureux
comment allez vous êtes en pleine forme
moi toujours toujours ainsi celui-ci
sait que ça va très bien on passe de
l'autre côté musique c'est un petit
nouveau dans cette émission mais je suis
sûr qu'il va faire des étincelles sur
les parquet de versailles on le compare
au basketteur lebron james bomba saïd
joueurs de l'ue lcv 78 ans ancien joueur
de trappes est avec nous pour noël
bonjour à tous bonjour mamba quand
allez-vous travaille avec des mieux
nantis peu de mal à vous retourner
donc un mètre 98 pour les
téléspectateurs à la précision qu'il
faudra pas trop l'énerver un stadier
ainsi comment vous sentez vous pour
votre première sa part fait pourquoi les
gens à côté de moi ou voilà j'ai perdu
tous mes rêves la dream team
bref j'en passe et au programme de
l'émission on va parler de cyclisme la
pépite de la piste
mathilde de gros tout juste 20 ans
depuis le 27 avril et au japon la
pistarde a quitté le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines pour
s'entraîner pendant deux mois dans le
pays du soleil levant
dans le cadre de sa formation la
sportive apprendra notamment les astuces
du keirin avec des professeurs sur place
une expérience qu'elle avait déjà
réalisée l'année dernière je rappelle
que le kerhinet une course sur piste
longue de 2 km et les adversaires
doivent se doubler jusqu'à remporter le
sprint final
la question sur cette thématique at elle
raison de partir là bas
oui ou non voter bamba non rouge vert
voilà vous êtes partagés
tous les verts mais vous n'en gens
pourquoi parce que j'ai deux séries vous
partagez donc je suis partagé parce que
je ne sais pas si le japon
personnellement j'ai jamais entendu
parler du japon comme grandes nations du
cyclisme donc aller s'entraîner là-bas
on aurait dit un autre pays je redis bah
oui parce que c'est vraiment mais là le
japon jamais ne lui parlez donc je suis
mitigé par le car mais ça me parle pas
personnellement après je n'ai pas toutes
les données donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit que je suis mitigé parce que voilà
j'ai pas les références au niveau du
japon dans le domaine du cyclisme jan
est-ce que vous pouvez lui donner les
références du japon dans le domaine du
cyclisme
mathilde est d'aller au japon pour
pratiquer le keirin de keirin est une
discipline japonaise à la base et la
basse et indiscipline qui a été créé au
japon en 1948 et là bas le keirin et
l'équivalent du sport hippique en france
c'est à dire que les gens peuvent parier
sur les sur les athlètes
donc il ya énormément d'argent mis en
mise en jeu et donc
donc il ya une vraie culture du keirin
du karine abba y lisons des des pistes
spécifique ils ont alors que c'est pas
la même chose que le keirin ans au
championnat du monde
mais voilà ce sont neuf sur la lys de 9
alors que nous on est 6 ya pas de moto
voilà c'est un petit peu différent mais
c'est vrai que c'est une épreuve qui est
très spectaculaire au japon mathilde a
besoin de toute façon d'expérience elle
a besoin de courir sur une période où en
france et en europe
il ya très peu de compétition donc pour
moi oui je moi je dis oui à la raison
d'y aller
et puis après on a aussi quand même
beaucoup de nos anciens athlètes
ils y allaient très régulièrement courir
au japon étaient invités à venir courir
françois pervis il va quasiment tous les
ans et sur ses grandes années et où il a
gagné deux médailles d'or aux vendeurs
du monde en 2014 et en 2015
voilà
florian rousseau ils y allaient aussi il
ya tous les ans il y a des certains
athlètes les meilleurs athlètes de
l'adie des disciplines sportives sont un
des sous du sprint sont invités à venir
faire les tournées sur une culture et de
et d'enrichissement d'expérience dans le
pays historique de la discipline comme
jean je ne savais pas que c'était c'est
est né au japon dont j'avais peut-être
cette règle quelques dégâts car pour moi
le haka ces questions un peu de vie
pique parfois des pour sauter les
chevaliers vous êtes convaincu il
convaincu par l'ailé à la fois je
partageais le point de vue de gens parce
que je ne savais pas que c'était un pays
culturellement impliqué dans l'histoire
du cyclisme sur piste et par les
explications de yann maintenant j'en
sais un peu plus on apprend des choses
tous les jours dans cette émission on
parle de sport formidable et de culture
il faut savoir que les athlètes
européens où les athlètes étrangers qui
viennent qui viennent au japon suivent
un stage d'une quinzaine ou d'un mois où
il ya des parce qu'il ait des pratiques
très à respecter par rapport au keirin
et ils ne font pas partie des athlètes
de très haut niveau sur le keirin là bas
c'est à dire qu'il y a des plusieurs
divisions et il ne rentre pas
directement en première division ils
font leurs classes et petit à petit il
monte de division pas peut-être pas
chaque année mais au cours et qui en
plus il ya un système de paris de paris
alors est vraiment vraiment très très
particulier se dire que les coureurs
sont obligés de donner la tactique
qu'ils vont employer pendant la course
en amont et donc du coup pour pour ne
pas influencer les enfin pour pouvoir
influencer les paris ou ne pas léser les
voilà donc c'est vraiment très donné le
braquer qui vont utiliser enfin il ya
plein de choses qui
c'est très très très très très sérieux
bon bah c'est qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous alors elle est déjà parti
une première fois au japon je le précise
et elle était l invité revient pas en
vacances
pau dans le cadre de sa formation elle
avait terminé 6e du keirin lors des
derniers championnats du monde en
pologne
finalement ça paye 6e franchement c'est
bien c'est bien on peut si elle va
gagner de l'expérience est donc voilà
donc un peu ces disciplines qu'on
connaît pas encore en france peut-être
plus tard pour informer de notre
d'autres gènes d'accord plus tard
positif le seul petit bémol rapide après
des bruits très rapidement à des
précipitations yann c'est que il nous a
dit que c'était là il cesse alignés sur
9 alors que c'est pas les mêmes
conditions finalement que les
championnats du monde
alors est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas quand
même une autre une autre nation il
s'amuse de tokyo où il ya plus de
concurrents mais sauf que les tactiques
sont pas les mêmes mais lorsque 19,9
cycliste bras croisés sprint race un
sprint ouais bien sûr et est donc c'est
quand même l'effort qui est recherché et
puis la capacité à trouver les trouver
l'ouverture
et ça c'est que en pratique en compte qu
on la reçoit non venez pas me couper
moi je voulais dire une chose c'est que
mathilde et chantier ce groupe devienne
leader
mathilde est championne d'europe aussi
du tiering et c'est après son premier
passage au japon qu'elle était revenu
qui avait empoché ce don clubs d'europe
et si la motion précise m aux
championnats du monde donc on verra bien
sûr que ça paye et mathilde a encore de
gros fin va encore faire de gros progrès
sujets suivants allaient alors nous
allons maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de la ryder cup 2018 la
compétition de golf qui s'est déroulé au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines a été primé en angleterre nous
font également un coup de projecteur sur
le bout de campe un camp militaire qui a
été organisée à saint germes en lait
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler rugby dans ce talk
[Musique]
du rugby dans cette page résultat les
versailles ils ont fait les joueurs de
la cité royale ont réussi leur pari ils
ont remporté ce dimanche 28 avril de
boucliers deux titres de champion
ile-de-france la réserve l'emportent 29
à 28 face aux cuves sur terrain neutre
et l'équipe première a réussi à battre
vincennes sur le score de 17 à 12
une saison historique pour le club
d'autant plus que l'équipe première est
invaincu cette saison en 20 matches une
petite réaction
pierre chevallier vous qui suivez cette
équipe de l1 très près de l'intérieur
derrière
comment ne pas dire ou à redire ce qu'on
a ce qu'on a dit en début de semaine à
travers votre plateau et vos émissions
depuis dimanche une une sorte d'euphorie
qui a gagné le rc versailles on avait
déjà acquis la montée en fédérale 3 qui
était l'objectif principal en avant sur
le timing donc l'aller les seigneurs
vous avez terminé invaincue en plus ils
terminent invaincues de 18 victoires en
18 matches c'était ça c'était le premier
bonus est donc là deux titres
franciliens qui est une première dans
l'histoire du club en réserve et en
première la réserve l'avait fait il ya
deux ans 2007 déjà ce qui était déjà une
belle performance mais la réaliser le
doublé quand on est attendu parce qu'on
était vraiment attendus sur ces finales
contre le skull sans réserve et contre
le rc vincennes en première qui est
l'autre qui est l'autre équipe ii
francilienne qui est montée en fédérale
3 delà de la poule 2 donc énormément de
fierté énormément de joie on a fêté ça
jusqu'à tard dans la nuit à dimanche au
club house sont allés chercher le très
difficile d'ailleurs de vous avoir été
les matins il fait il voit un petit peu
caverneuse aurait sûrement ils sont
allés chercher ce deuxième ce deuxième
bonus
et puis maintenant il ya les
championnats de france qui démarre donc
de sur tous les plans on en parle depuis
le début de la saison sur ce plateau
notamment mais c'est une saison comme on
en vit pas pas tous les pas tous les
quatre matins quand tout quand tout se
déroule bien quand tout s'enchaîne bien
il ya un très bon groupe les le groupe
seniors réserve première étant une vraie
bande de potes et ça joue sajou
énormément sauveur au rugby est donc là
ils peuvent aller le plus loin possible
pour ce écrire leur propre histoire
leurs propres souvenirs mais il ya déjà
deux titres pour se souvenir de cette
saison comme une saison vraiment
historique jean rioux surprennent
versailles avant de passer à la question
sur la thématique
il veut surprennent c'est toujours bien
de réaliser le doublé comme ils l'ont
fait pour moi ce n'est pas une surprise
parce qu'ils étaient quand même
largement au dessus de tout le monde
après les résultats une finale reste une
finale c'est la preuve en est les
résultats d'un point en réserve et de
400 points en première et parce qu'une
finale reste une finale après pour moi
ce n'est pas une surprise des zones
tellement la preuve
invaincus sont tellement régner sur sur
le championnat
en honneur il était largement au dessus
donc pour moi il n'y a pas de surprise
pour moi ya pas de surprise après ça
reste ça reste ça reste une énorme une
énorme performance mettre les deux deux
équipes en haut avec le bouclier au
niveau régional
c'est l'aboutissement
l'aboutissement de deux pas des rêves
mais dans l'objectif pour l'instant on
va passer la question sur cette
thématique cette domination peut-elle
durer
est ce que cette domination que durée
oui ou non
oui pour bamba non pour ont fait un
petit duel entre bamba et les gens d'en
bas mais est ce que voulait commencer je
vous l'envoie nouveau nom mais je pense
que ça peut ça peut continuer je suis
pas trop le début mai d'après ce que
j'ai 13 14 le mental moteur et
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien faire
autant vous montez ces dernières et donc
comme vous êtes sur une bonne dynamique
je pense que d'après ce que j'ai compris
à des bons jeunes et tout ça donc ça pas
les lois et des jeunes également
il ya des jeunes aussi oui c'est pour ça
j'essaie à des jeunes et que ça palais
loin donc ils peuvent continuer leur
progression
jean c'est à vous moi j'ai mis nombre
exprès pour faire la contradiction parce
que sinon j'aurais fait comme pierre
j'aurais mis entre les deux pourquoi
parce que bien sûr je viens de le dire
il survolait le championnat honneur
sauf que là il monte il monte d'une
division même si d'honneur à fédérale 3
sur ce qu'ils ont montré et sur le
collectif qu'ils ont en place on le voit
d'ailleurs d'après des années avant
toutes les équipes qui montent tout
l'honneur et qui ont ce dynamisme et
cette dynamique et ce groupe réalise de
belles performances en fédérale 3
maintenant forcément vu qu'ils montrent
des niveaux qu'ils auront pas ils
n'auront pas le même aura qu'ils ont vu
cette saison ils vont devenir on va dire
le pas le petit on va dire le bleu
moyens le moyenne de la fédérale 3 c'est
à dire le
le milieu de tableau de la fédérale 3
peut-être je dis bien peut-être après
sur la dynamique sur après le
recrutement à l'intersaison aussi parce
qu'il y aura certainement recrutement en
fonction dieu de la montée en fédérale 3
et peuvent très bien on l'a vu comme
sarcelles par exemple la saison dernière
qui a empêché d'ailleurs versailles de
montée la saison dernière puisque
c'était ni plus ni moins une saison de
moins gros versailles pour la montée
parce qu'ils avaient sarcelles et qu'il
y avait une énorme écuries et on a vu
que sercel à l'intersaison l'an dernier
est monté en fédérale 3 et et joue le
haut de tableau ils ont fini premiers de
poule parce qu'ils ont refait en ocotbre
énorme de joueurs de fédérale 2 et
fédérale hull et ils sont premiers de
poule en fédérale 3 et je voulais phase
finale du championnat de france donc
tout dépendra de leur recrutement
doxi recrute jeu j'aurais tendance à
dire oui ils continueront sur une une
lancée comme ils ont fait un honneur
comme celle là fait cette saison ci
reste avec le groupe l'a forcément ils
vont tomber sur les écuries qui sont un
petit peu plus tard mais est habitué à
ce niveau de la fédérale 3 je pense que
si un quart des gardes et la base aussi
c'est important
c'est très important c'est la base l'apa
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
sur eux ils convaincus par jean et c'est
pour ça que j'étais un gt est mitigé la
première raison joint jean l'a résumé
c'est la montée de la montée de division
évidemment qui va se faire avec une
montée niveau avec des équipes qui sont
en fédérale 3 depuis plus longtemps que
nous nous étions descendus il ya trois
ans et après après une dizaine d'années
on fédérale 3 mais il ya un niveau
d'écart entre l'honneur et fédérale 3 de
fait est la deuxième raison gens là un
peu évoquée c'est justement la
physionomie du groupe en avant-première
ce qu'il faut avouer et dire à demi mot
c'est qu'on a une partie de ce groupe
qui va qui va terminer le cycle de trois
ans de remonter parce que c'est
finalement pas si facile que ça de
remonter d'honneur à fédérale 3 c1
un travail de longue haleine et dans ce
groupe il y a il y a une petite dizaine
douzaine de joueurs répartis entre la
première et la réserve qui vont arrêter
qui vont qui vont prendre leur retraite
ça dd papa qui arrêtent qu'ils arrêtent
leur carrière en voyage enlevée le
capitaine il y en a certains certains
joueurs qui ont qui sont venus prendre
part à l'aventuré de versailles il ya
quelques années qui vont s'arrêter là
dessus donc ça va éviter effectivement
dépendent de nos très crue dans de
recrutement de notre capacité à nous
renouveler et surtout de de tirer profit
d'un des objectifs que l'on avait c'est
l'objectif axé sur la formation
c'est à dire de faire monter des juniors
en senior en réserve et en première pour
pouvoir renforcer les troupes
on avait dans ces deux groupes champion
d'île de france
on avait une petite dizaine de juniors
montant de cette année qui ont pris part
à cette épopée à toute la saison et à ce
titre régional donc à ceux à ce titre
sur pour ces deux raisons je serai
prudent et puis surtout aussi par par
humilité pour ne pas trop prendre le
bocal et surtout de ne pas vendre la
peau de l'ours avant de l'avoir tué en
fédérale 3 viennent du veyrier ge avons
le bocal comme le dit fernand et puis il
faut pas tuer le lapin avant de voilà
avant de temps que la triche cheval
voilà voilà non mais moi je vais aussi
mitigé parce que alors je connais pas
énormément le rugby sur les divisions
inférieures que c'est tout on peut
discuter mais par contre ce que je
retiens depuis depuis je fais c'est
depuis je fais les émissions et vous
c'est que la marche entre chaque
division est toujours très haute et
toujours eric hall à l'époque sauf que
là elle ne l'est pas un drone heures et
fédérale 3 po et oui quand 7 2 6 3
quelle est l importance honneur ce droit
par expérience et par rapport à
l'histoire
tous les clubs comme filles le tableau
en honneur se sont très bien comportés
en fédérale 3 la notamment en ile de
france où vient beaucoup il ya beaucoup
d'ex beaucoup d'éclat donc mais à la
marche
mauger non mais non non mais donc voila
moi je mets jeu mais quand même mitigé
et c'est vrai que ben ce que tu viens de
dire avec le départ enfin l'arrêt d'une
grosse dizaine de gars voilà fait que
ben le groupe va être peut-être
affaiblies ou modifiées et donc il va
falloir intégrer du du sang neuf là
dedans une équipe de rugby c'est pas
juste quinze mecs sur un terrain c'est
une trentaine donc du coup ça veut dire
qu'il ya un tiers du un tiers de
l'effectif à renouveler et puis la csu
miser sur les deux équipes donc ça veut
dire que peut-être peut-être même 45
peut-être même 45 il faut que les
joueurs qu'on va intégrer
je suis donc donc voila moi aussi mitigé
parce que ben une marche une marche une
nouvelle marche à conquérir
et puis après c'est pareil par contre
par contre après sait quels sont les
objectifs du club
est ce que c'est de se dire nous on veut
continuer à grimper ou alors on veut se
stabiliser en f3 et en fédérale 3 et
donc et pour avoir une accession la
dernière question pierre chevallier
c'est plus serré l'objectif c'est là
étant en étant on va dire cohérence et
c'est milieu de tableau le maintien
l'année prochaine en fédérale 3
l'appétit vient en mangeant après
derrière donc c'est se stabiliser en
fédérale 3 ce que j'ajoute c'est que on
note grâce à cette bonne actualité
le fait d'avoir fait une saison
historique les deux titres régionaux
ça ça mais les projecteurs sur
versailles dont il ya certains joueurs
qui nous contactent en ce moment
spontanément pour pouvoir venir venir
jouer chez nous et on a à mon hôte aussi
quelques retours de deux joueurs qui
étaient partis pour études travail aux
autres et qui reviennent jouer à
versailles souvent parler chez vous avec
vos jeunes petits soucis
l'aïe à toulouse on va continuer à
parler à au rugby dans notre rubrique
focus du rugby encore et toujours la
rumeur enfle depuis plusieurs jours et
elles devraient être confirmés d'ici
début juin une partie du ska et rugby de
montigny le bretonneux pourraient
fusionner à la rentrée prochaine idée
principale serait de regrouper en une
seule et même équipe seniors les deux
entités l'équipe qui aurait un nouveau
non serait amenée à évoluer en promotion
honneur division dans laquelle évolue le
sky rugby les féminines de montigny le
bretonneux qu'on s'a vrai quand elle
leur nom et leur statut ces décisions
sera étudié lors de l'assemblée générale
des deux clubs phares mais la question
sur ce thème
est ce que c'est une bonne idée je vois
que ça hésite bas bon bah pourquoi vous
hésitez je vous vois président en tout
cas trois sur quatre sont hésitants
ouais parce que en fait en général les
fusions il ya tellement de problèmes et
que
donc du coup ça dure pas longtemps ça
dure pas longtemps et après ça dépend
d'eux
dans les deux équipes quelle est
l'équipe la plus forte c'est le style
voilà donc après il faut en dire est ce
que l'autre équipe vont accepter de
lâcher des joueurs est de former une
autre équipe voilà donc c'est un peu
après aussi à la politique ça joue aussi
des deux clubs
est ce qu'ils seront dans la même
longueur d'onde voilà donc c'est pour
moi c'est un peu genre joue sans
sceptiques aussi sur cette finale oui
c'est non je ne suis pas sceptique sur
la fusion c'est malheureusement je
dirais malheureusement ce qu'on voit de
plus en plus parce que le rugby français
quand même ne va pas bien on se on se
voile un petit peu la face et c'est une
fusion par obligation parce que il
mannequin iman qu' il manque de joueurs
tout simplement
et que si les deux clubs ne fusionne pas
elles et ils vont disparaître chacun de
leur côté parce que mais il ya un manque
réel de joueurs dû certainement aussi à
plein de choses et l'on va pas rentrer
mais sans de sérieux problèmes
économiques l'appareil économique est
moins de joueurs ça rien à voir avec
l'économie c'est un problème de joueurs
de rugby le mal en ce moment il y est
ils existent ils
on nous dit on nous dira on a beau nous
dire au niveau de la fédération
française de rugby qu'on est en
augmentation de licenciés mais c'est de
la poudre aux yeux
le rugby tel qu'il est le rugby à quinze
tel qu'il se pratique de base il est en
diminution de licenciés et c'est pour ça
qu'on voit se multiplier ce genre de
fusion parce que mais les équipes les
clubs en entité unique ne peuvent pas
subvenir aux obligations sportives et
c'est pour ça qu'on le voit alors c'est
certainement dû aussi à la
multiplication des catégories on a le
cingle le fly le dise le 7 le 12 le 15
le 13 mai il ya trop de trop de chiffres
qui disperse la mesa disperse nombre de
licenciés sur des disques de multiples
disciplines et alors qu'avant c'était
concentrer sur lequel il y avait le 15
le 13 et le 7 et c'était pour une finale
donc on avait une concentration de
joueurs dans un premier temps qui était
résolument porté vers le 15
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu plus
diffus
et donc on a de moins en moins de
joueurs et ce genre de phénomène de
fusion de club pour continuer d'exister
et bien c'est malheureusement
malheureusement inéluctable peut-être
mais on va là est la pierre a fait
passer un message
il a tout à fait raison la formation
d'une bulle psy voilà la formation la
formation est une des réponses à ce
genre de phénomène parce que mettre
l'accent sur les jeunes mais on
s'aperçoit aussi que au niveau des
jeunes au niveau cadet juniors il ya
énormément pour de multiples raisons on
va pas rentrer dans les détails de perte
de joueurs entre eux cadets juniors et
seniors vers qu'à l'arrivée en seniors
il ya beaucoup moins de joueurs que à la
normale quoi et c'est malheureusement
donc pour finir ce genre de fusion se
multiplient de plus en plus pourquoi tu
es d'exister pierre chevallier je vous
donne la parole à prayssas ryan
dujarrier évidemment c'est c'est pour
versailles c'est un problème de riche
entre guillemets parce qu on a 600
licenciés mais on a on a démarré on a
démarré le la formation justement il ya
très longtemps
notre école de rugby compte 250 250
enfants jusqu'à 14 ans après il ya le
pôle jeunes et puis les seniors on a on
a toujours pris le scolaire comme un
code notamment comme un point de
développement même si ya assez peu de
transformations quand on fait des
événements dans les écoles des
transformations en licencier jean le dit
à demi-mot ça ça mériterait un débat
complet sur ce plateau le rugby français
va pas forcément très bien parce qu'il
est mauvaise presse en ce moment il ya
des idées des problèmes de violence et
des problèmes de 2
violence des chocs des chocs sur le
terrain il ya eu malheureusement trois
décès successifs récemment donc le rugby
a fait les gros titres mais pas pour les
bonnes raisons
et là je comprends les pères et les
mères qui hésite désormais à mettet
enfants au rugby formé pour durer à
versailles ça parce d'abord par la
culture et parades par là la culture du
jeu de rugby qui est de remettre du
mouvement de la vitesse et de l' esquive
plutôt que de faire comme comme le rugby
est depuis quelques années c'est à dire
un sport de collision n'ont plus de
contacts de collision est donc désormais
on rassure tout le monde
en formant les enfants à travers un jeu
de mouvement et de vitesse
donc c'est là c'est là où il faut former
et montré que le rugby est un reste le
fantastique sport que jean et moi avons
connu qui continue à connaître vos
quotidiens le pour répondre à la
question de la fusion de certains clubs
etc pour faire face à la réalité la
réplication des dix ans y est
effectivement avec une une baisse des
effectifs une baisse des effectifs chez
les jeunes chez les ch et chez les
adultes et qui fait que certains clubs
pour survivre doivent se rapprocher
moi j'étais mitigé pour l'aspect non pas
sur les raisons mais sur la haine sur
l'aspect à venir avec une perte de
cultures de l'un ou l'autre ou des deux
clubs est de savoir en gros comment la
mayonnaise peut prendre on n'a pas
encore tous les éléments sont là bien
sûr mais on les a jamais on ne les a
jamais réellement à la vente sans ces
éléments là mais pour une fusion réussie
il faut qu'il y en ait automatiquement
un qui qu'ils fassent un peu plus de
sacrifices que le deuxième club qui
fusionne donc c'est mitigé sur le sur
les sur l'avenir pas sur les raisons
malheureusement les comprendre et nous
on est on est les premiers ajustements
essayer de ceux de se battre pour faire
croître les effectifs
et les licenciés en rugby il ya nigeria
et vous étiez le seul pour finalement
les raisons pour lesquelles je suis pour
c'est que pour moi
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'est une
ville nouvelle enfin a été construit
comme une ville nouvelle et donc on
devrait avoir dans chaque dans chaque
sport l'équipe numéro un devrait faire
partie des meilleurs joueurs de toute la
communauté d'agglomération et c'est pour
cette raison que je que je dis oui il
faut maintenant c'est loin d'être le cas
parce que ben tout le monde fait ce type
de guerre de clochers et souhaite avoir
et garder ses meilleurs joueurs qui l'a
formé alors que l'objectif serait que
ben chaque petit club soient fiers de
pouvoir fournir la grosse équipe de son
sport et qui soit celle de saint quentin
en yvelines et non pas celle de l
encours de trappes ou deux ça c'est le
monde point de vue il serait ruby c'est
ça finalement parce qu'il ya déjà une
fusion entre le club n'existe que depuis
2008 il y avait avant saint cyr l'école
voisins bretons ne lui en cours maurepas
elancourt ils ont tous fusionner à
montigny-le-bretonneux par exemple à
l'époque mais maintenant quelques années
mais aujourd'hui c'est le cas pour les
raisons que jean et xavière et pierre
que j'en ai bien on l'annonçait et le
problème c'est que ces raisons là elles
sont valables pour tous les sports s'est
pas seulement dans le rugby que ça va
mal c'est dans le vélo nous aussi on
nous dit tout va bien il ya de plus en
plus de ya de plus en plus de licenciés
sauf que oui mais sauf que tout plus de
dossiers qui font du cyclotourisme et
non pas du sig et non pas du cyclisme et
donc on se retrouve avec des
compétitions il ya de moins en moins de
participants
et ça c'est vraiment problématique dans
le football est bien l'équipe nationale
fait que sa rentrée c'est le sport c'est
le sport numéro un mais dans beaucoup de
sports un peu plus petit j'imagine que
dans le basket c'est pareil d'avoir des
années où c'est un peu plus compliqué de
recruter d'avoir des des jeunes qui
rentrent et puis ben voilà on se cache
derrière des pratiques loisirs
aujourd'hui beaucoup de sport ou de
moins en moins de compétiteurs très
rapidement juste pour finir sur
sujet c'est que toutes les fusions et ça
c'est l'histoire qui le dit c'est
vraiment toutes les fusions ou alors ça
n'a pas duré
ou alors il ya toujours un club qui a
pris le dessus sur l'autre et à voir
disparaître carrément le n 2 du club à
l'avenir
je précise que ce n'est pas encore
officiel donc il faut rester prudent sur
cette fusion
cap sur saint germain en laye à présent
un entraînement digne des militaires ou
des pompiers baptisé bootcamp était
organisée ce samedi 27 avril dans la
commune avec les pompiers de paris une
vingtaine de personnes a souffert
pendant une matinée au programme pompe
traction course à pied les réactions
micro de tv 78 c'est sympa ça change de
l'ordinaire en plus on a de la chance
parce que il peut pas donc non ça sympa
ça fait travailler un peu trop d'argent
les muscles du corps en pleine fc c'est
génial ça fait du bien à l'écouté un
groupe sympa on bonne ambiance c'est
fait
la question vous sur ce thème les
bootcamp sont ils juste un effet de mode
ou non du tour de table
le premier qui a élevé le bâti de
pancartes c'est pierre chevalier je
dirais que c'est pas un effet de mode
parce que je pense que les sports en
amont la course à pied notamment et le
cros fille par exemple qui ont aussi un
autre que le un autre sport à la mode
sont appelées à durer parce que ben on
en parlait juste avant c'est ce sont des
sports qui nécessitent pas vraiment de
d'investissements lourds ça s'adresse à
vraiment toute la population les jeunes
les moins jeunes les hommes les femmes
et c'est certain ce sont des sports qui
sont assez en vogue parce que c'est en
gros pour le bien-être faire une
activité physique manger cinq fruits et
légumes par jour et ça c'est très dense
et très dans l'air du temps
donc là c'est un axe sp
fille que à ce type de sport parle la
culture plutôt militaire et de la
culture physique mais en tout cas saab
est ça amène sûrement un certain nombre
de françaises et de français à se se
poser la question de la pratique du
sport régulière donc à ce titre là comme
la course à pied je pense que c'est
amené à durer bon bah qu'est ce qui fait
que ça plaît le bund convaincu
copé fait pas trop et donc non mais
c'est bien de ses gérants de ce corps
donc ça vous retrouve tous en même temps
et je pense que pour la santé si bien
c'est bien voilà vous êtes convaincu
voilà jean jacques martin y aura le
temps que tu vas finir non moi je moi
j'étais mitigé parce que je connaissais
pas donc je que je connaissais pas le
bootcamp
donc c'est pour ça que j'étais un petit
peu mitigé après c'est ça existe depuis
la fin des années 90 aux états unis mais
les passagers tout connaître
comme le dit pierre commun dit pierre
d'ailleurs on apprend tous les jours et
qu'elle tombe bien ce qui se passe tout
particulièrement ici donc non je ne le
connaissais pas maintenant est une
activité physique qui est bien et en
plus c'est physique et mentale
donc à mon avis ça doit aussi intéresser
pas mal de d'entreprises parce que c'est
le petit peu à la mode de faire des
stages de cohésion de cohésion physique
et mentale à travers les entreprises
donc je pense que ça c'est une porte
ouverte
et quoi qu'il en soit ça c'est une
activité physique et qui dit activité
physique dit c'est du bonus c'est tout
bon c'est tout bon c'est pas comme le
moment hongqi pas bon du tout et où il
faut pas en abuser non plus par exemple
avec modération tout avec modération
il ya du jardin
j'vois pierre il a fallu 100 chefs
bouche comme tout le monde donc c'est
pas évident alors moi je considère pas
que c'est un sport et tu as employés
bons mots c'est une activité physique
parce que pour moi non à la différence
entre un sport une activité physique
c'est qu'un sport on accroche un dossard
alors le rugby je n'accroche pas de
charme on a le maillot du club et on a
un chiffre dans le dos et voilà on fait
une compétition et là ils font pas de
compétition n'y a pas de ligne d'arrivée
on est là pour faire une
on est là pour faire un activités
physiques et en plus elle a tout le
sourire quand je vois ça veut dire que
on n'est quand même pas non plus dans le
dépassement de dans le dépassement de
soi avec des filles il va t'arriver que
des femmes et les seniors
c'est donc après c'est sur une matinée
donc ça va c'est trois heures d'ag la
route quand ça se passe sur plusieurs
semaines
voilà plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs
mois et donc là je pense que on va aller
chercher un bien le qr2 soft sur 4 5
heures de donc là est donc bon là je
pense que c'était c'est plus dans les
esprits dans l'esprit sympathique et
bonne entente et donc activité physique
est par contre je te rejoins pierre
c'est que je le redis pour pas l'oublier
c'est que c'est que c'est complètement
dans la mode avec les mud des et toutes
ses courses où on va aller courir dans
la boue les courses de couleur là où on
en met partout aussi et c'est un petit
peu dans le même esprit chercheurs bien
sûr mais on risque et vagabond ils
voient les images injustement le mend et
le principe c'est aussi c'est pareil
c'est qu'on est prêt à organiser la
peine dans les yvelines on n'est pas là
pour vous chronométré en l'air vous vous
remettrez pour donner un temps mais il
n'y a pas de classement on a tout le
monde est content juste d'arriver
et donc on ne relève l'esprit
compétition est lent et le côté je veux
dire que ce sont des épreuves pour hâter
de fer à 80% on n'ira pas se mettre à 95
ou à 100% du solide à ce jour 10 % il ya
l'esprit de solidarité et je pense qu'il
ya des gens qui sont assez importants ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut préciser c'est
que tu as raison de dire que ce n'est
pas forcément une compétition par contre
l'objectif c'est pas de faire un temps
sur un mode d séparés sur route quand
c'est fini c'est fini
et là dans le sur le bootcamp ce qui est
ce qu'il faut aussi préciser c'est que
c'est quand même tu as tu as quand même
une forme de dépassement de soi parce
que ce sont des méthodes des méthodes
militaires d'entraînement avec avec pas
forcément beaucoup de beaucoup
d'accessoires le côté préparation des
qui peut des équipes de sports
collectifs type foot type rubis le fait
souvent parfois je pense à certaines
préparations qu'on avait fait nous
attend à versailles avec le gign à
satory et c'est là il ya vraiment quand
même dû qu'à radio de la culture
physique ça va puiser quand même dans le
monde à nez avec des personnes qui ont
l'habitude le lard et à le faire et très
complet de jeu le sportif 16 ans atteint
du même état
quand j'allais quand il est obligé de se
dépasser pour aller chercher un objectif
le mental va permettre de dépasser des
capacités que l'on a faim je dire
j'attends que sara ziff de haut niveau
en tant que sportif de haut niveau il ya
des moments on va se mettre dans des
états de fatigue pour pouvoir augmenter
nos performances sur ce type de
d'activité physique on ne le fait pas on
le fait pour avoir un sport bien être et
c'est pour ça que je moi je milite sur
la différence entre activité physique et
compétition ce sont vraiment de deuxième
set a raison mais ça va au delà de la
mode et parce que parce que la seule
mode d où le volcan s'est finalement on
y va pour ans
en ch hiver mais on se mettra pas non
pour se mesurer
bon bah qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est vrai que si j'écoute bien yann
c'est que il ya une différence entre
l'activité physique et le sport donc du
coup je suis je suis entraîné dur mais
je suis je partage plus de la vie de
l'autre versailles et c'est pour ça tu
fais un petit tour de table qui seraient
prêts à tester un lebootcamp on mais moi
j'y vais on le voit déjà testé le
quidditch avec vous à johnny chassez
fait oui je le fais un sport tiré de la
saga harry potter
on passe maintenant notre page débats
[Musique]
dans notre débat aujourd'hui du golfe la
ryder cup 2018 a été nommé événement
sportif de l'année la semaine dernière à
londres par le prestigieux bureau
britannique de l'industrie du sport le
tournoi qui a vu les européens s'imposer
face aux états unis sur le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli
près de 270 mille fans venus du monde
entier fin septembre l'événement a
également a battu le record d'articles
parus dans la presse et près d'un
milliard de personnes ont vu cette ryder
cup française à la télévision
la prochaine édition aura lieu en 2020
dans le wisconsin aux états unis la
question sur ce thème
êtes vous d'accord la ryder cup 2018
était le plus grand événement sportif de
l'année 2018
oui il ya toujours des travaux
scientifiques
évidemment a évidemment en tant que
golfeur convenu qu ayant eu la chance de
participer justement l'organisation de
cette de cet événement c'était déjà le
troisième événement médiatique au monde
derrière les jo et la coupe du monde de
foot là on a cette chance de l'avoir eue
sur le golf national en france en
septembre
il ya deux choses mais qui m'inspire au
delà au delà de l'est de l'événement
lui-même c'est que un c'est la
reconnaissance du travail accompli par
le comité ryder cup français qui à bien
exploiter l'ensemble des l'ensemble du
cahier des charges du
du comité américain et britannique qui
détient les droits de l'événement c'est
en deuxième un formidable coup de
projecteur sur le savoir faire savoir
faire français sur l'organisation
d'évènements c'est en fait mais aussi
aussi sur le golf est désormais le golf
national comme ryder cup pnue qui est
justement 7,7 ce parcours de golf qui
peut qui peut attirer désormais un
certain nombre de golfeurs du monde
entier puisque c'est là où s'est déroulé
ce magnifique événement et qui a drainé
qui a drainé les foules en septembre
dernier
alors on va s'intéresser quand même aux
autres nommés dans la catégorie à plus
grand événement d'année pour les
britanniques
il y avait notamment la coupe du monde
de hockey sur gazon féminine
il y avait le e s éloigne birmingham une
compétition de heath porte le tournoi du
queen's en tennis six courses
d'équitation de leur box elle ce grand
national et wimbledon
bien sûr et on voit justement à l'image
en 2018 il y avait quand même d'autres
événements qui n'était pas du coup dans
la liste il y avait par exemple onzième
sacre de nadal à roland garros la coupe
du monde de football en russie
les championnats d'europe de handball
féminin en france avec la victoire des
françaises et les jo d'hiver en corée du
sud
est ce qu'on peut dire que la ryder cup
est quand même à 10 015 e la cause d'une
offre du monde de foot allemand aurait
dû remporter mais le drame c'est que
l'angleterre ils ont fait quoi me mary
ça c'est puel mais en mieux
à partir de là à partir de ce moment là
si drôle de sélection comme ça comme
c'est comme c'est un jury anglais c'est
quelque chose britanniques ces voix là
est ce qu'une loi britannique
l'angleterre je me souviens même pas
qu'ils aient leur parcours en 2018 la
demi finale demi-finales ouais ouais et
et pourtant donc voila et bains commune
on va gagner et que les ont pas gagné
bas du cou
et c'est vrai oui le fait s'il avait dit
la coupe du monde dans la mesure où
c'est les français qui l'ont remporté en
russie
on voit que les britanniques vont élire
meilleure compétition une compétition où
la phrase a gagné avec ce solide surtout
rattachés à des éléments qui sont
déroulées sur leur territoire mois ci
ont ils organisé par une agence la halle
à travers le golfe
la radio comme les britanniques se sont
identifiés puisque c'est l'europe est
née à gagner donc c'est pour ça parce
qu'on connaît quand leur mentalité on va
pas non plus faire des erreurs c'est
quand on est cadre leur mentalité et on
sait pertinemment que si l'on me la h
cup
si j'avais gagné la coupe du monde de
football et virer pas photo qu'ils
auraient dit la concision de football et
ce que j'ai dis donc c'est leur
mentalité et comme ils se sont comme
l'euro a gagné à la ryder cup donc ce
soit avec des anglais dans l'équipe et
je suis forcément coco et vous auriez
voté pour la ryder cup ou
personnellement a besoin par exemple ou
de handball aux deux bâle champion du
monde de handball où le jeune champion
qu'on allait des bobos résultat qu'un
chien faut pas oublier martin fourcade
et ça que ça n'avance et une servante
ans a fait sa vie de plus d'un an donc
l'embarras en basket
sais pas quoi offrir rapidement du coup
quel événement en 2012 a marqué vous en
tant que la prison du monde numéro comme
de monde sur la ryder cup fausse juste
se souvenir que vraiment les fées
s'étaient penchées sur ce berceau des
quêtes où il ya quasiment tout il ya eu
une météo fantastique une préparation du
parcours du golf national par les
équipes de polars mitage de directeur et
alejandro reyes le superintendant
absolument fantastique
tiger woods qui finalement gagne un
tournoi la semaine précédente et
s'aligne sur l'équipe américaine de
ryder cup ça ça fait énormément
et puis l'europe qui gagne au final avec
eu un engouement et une ferveur qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait voir qu'il fait
des vivres le dimanche une dimanche du
dernier tour donc c'est sûr justement
l'exposition médiatique dont vous
parliez et l'exposition locale sur le
sport sur un go et sur le golf qui reste
quand même un sport qui est qui peine à
séduire les plus grands le plus grand
nombre et des plus grandes foules
le seul bémol c'est que ça n'aura pas
pour l'instant créer des vocations et
ramener énormément de joueurs et de
nouveaux licenciés dans les clubs pour
l'instant cela seul bémol je veux saluer
pierre fait que l'arrestation était très
très bien très bien ficelé et surtout
pour moi il m'a quand même un gros gros
point noir sur le flanc gauche a sonné
c'était le nombre pour pouvoir
accueillir le fan martin pour pour
accueillir tous les visiteurs et même ce
point là a été réglé et voilà ça a été
très très bien la grande
une qui faisait 6000 places au départ du
ans c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de la ryder cup qui avait
autant de monde
au tour maintenant on en a parlé cinq
départs durant ce golf ce golf qui
permet de pouvoir voir plusieurs atouts
plusieurs trous et effacer des faits
pour ça il est fait pour se protéger on
espère que ça c'est ça essais de produit
qu'une seule fois mais une seule fois
chaque cargo lf accueille deux fois la
ryder cup c'est ça que je voulais dire
et j'espère que le coach national ne le
sera à nouveau sera nouveau ils ont pris
hôtes de cet acte de cette compétition
sauf un mot de la fin sur cette
thématique
ils viennent du j'arrive on passe
maintenant notre page découverte dans
cette page découverte nous allons parler
de cryothérapie un processus de soin par
le froid qui se pratique dans une cabine
nous avons reçu dans le 7-8 sport l'un
des précurseurs de cette technique en
france philippe cros basée dans les
yvelines nous présente la cryothérapie
la cryothérapie est un traitement par le
froid un froid extrême parce qu'en
décembre pendant trois minutes à -150
degrés là c'est à pour tout ce qui est
récupération c'est quelque chose de très
important c'est utilisé au départ parce
pour ça et c'est un ancien fleuron en
traumatologie s'est énormément utilisé
aussi c'est un anti inflammatoire
naturel un antalgique très très puissant
un entier de matheux un anti stress à un
antalgique et donc un anti-infectieux
aussi donc il ya un panel de patients
très très important une méthode qui a
l'air de plaire aux sportifs on écoute
les réactions
c'est pas instantanée mais après enfin
mme aussi à l'issue d'une opération je
me suis fait opérer des ligaments
croisés c'est par rapport à ça pour
avoir une meilleure récupération suite à
mon opération
super comme d'hab on appris en un peu
mais c'est de la sensation d'après donc
mois après certains gros entraînements
bah tu viens là bas ça ça fait du bien
c'est comme si tu mettais ton dont on
encore dans un glaçon et puis tu en
ressors ans a en tout cas j'en sens de
bons effets après la question sur ce
thème est ce que vous y croyez
oui bon bah oui alors bon bah vous avez
une petite anecdote un rapport à la
cryothérapie je vais déjà fait six tués
commencez pas sexuel face à sur le
plateau je l' ai déjà fait quand j'étais
avant donc voilà on a fait une séance
franchement c'est bien c'est bien pour
les petits plats sur petites blessures
et tout ça ça en retard mieux on
récupère bien
vous l'avez senti oui oui mais j'ai
senti
oui c'est les goûts alors hier alors la
cuy la crise
alors l'année la grille au lac rio la
classe et le modernisme qui veut ça mais
je vous rappelle qu'un que cela fait ça
fait ça fait des décennies que en blanc
on le plonge dans des poubelles de glace
rempli de glaçons après les matchs de
rugby notamment pour enlever tout ce qui
est justement récupération et tout ce
qui est mato tout ce qui est choquant et
pour la récupération et tout ce qui est
bien sûr et mathon donne pour les bières
gaufres et un rien à voir leur
agglomération avec modération mais après
les matches ça existe depuis très très
longtemps donc là heureusement on ait eu
sur une aire qui se modernise donc
maintenant on fait des centres et des
cabines exprès
et j'ai eu la chance de les voir venir a
plaisir à deux reprises avec le rugby
donc effectivement c'est c'est très bien
c'est très très bien c'est très efficace
surtout très bien ce n'est pas très bien
c'est pas un phénomène de mode
c'est vraiment efficace les les sportifs
ressentent vraiment une un résultat quoi
pierre j'ai plus un plus un accord avec
les plus enfin rapport agence je me
souviens de ces séances seront plongés
dans les poubelles de glace on le met ce
qu'on a gagné au moins 60 degrés non pas
du tout non pas du tout mais je pense
que le don de ça prouve que ça va péter
ça va plus loin plus loin ça va plus
loin mais le les vertus du froid ne sont
plus à faire pour les sportifs notamment
quand il ya des chocs et des conclusions
des coups là rien que les glaçons
s'était déjà déjà efficace il ya les
bombes de froid il ya tous les poches
les poches de glace qu'on met dans un
congélateur et comment vous qu'on sort
de chez soi évidemment là on passe un
cap on s'adresse aussi à des clubs de
niveau supérieur
parce que je pense que les soins sont un
petit peu plus coûteux à mettre en place
ou à prodiguer que qu'un simple une
simple poubelle de classe en revanche ça
se généralise justement ce dans tous les
sports professionnels je pense au
cyclisme notamment avec les îles les
caravanes itinérantes de cryothérapie a
priori qui sont sur le tour de france
notamment chez tous les sportifs
a priori c'est unanime c'est la
compagnie d'ailleurs le tour de france
mais qui je pense est amené est amené
effectivement à durer à partir du moment
où elle a fait ses preuves au nigeria
moi j'aime cette année note aussi je
n'ai pas encore testé mais en effet
juste le fait d'en parler
jusque là vous donne envie mais oui
parce que vu les commandes et les
souffrances que j'endure au quotidien
depuis depuis plusieurs semaines je
pense que je peux avoir besoin de ce
genre de ce genre de choses par contre
petite anecdote c'est qu'il ya un centre
à suresnes qui qui fait ce type de
propos ce type de soins et un jour ils
ont vu arriver des mares pour faire une
pour faire une séance vers le football
il faut vous ricanez marc excusez moi un
beau temps pierre et donc neymar est
venu il a fait sa séance et à la fin de
la séance
ben ce que ça vous a plu oui c'est
génial j'adore je veux je veux en faire
quand est-ce que vous revenez non non je
vais en acheter une pour la maison
pouvoir toujours plus apparemment ça
marche pas si bien que ça apparemment
couronne alba leed or de glissades en
partie là il a commandé la machine
directement chez le fabricant est ce que
tous les clubs doivent s'équiper en
détention touma m haies 12 au 15 du coup
c'est c'est plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros je crois en tout cas
oui mais non mais ces mêmes et le cnrs
comme ça c'est pas donné
je crois que ça peu près une centaine de
rue pour les 160 dresser sur on continue
cette page découverte par un événement
qui a du chien le refuge spa de plaisir
à organiser ce dimanche 28 avril dans la
forêt de plaisir son dixième canicross
le concept les participants devaient
courir 5 km 5 leur chien ou un chien de
la spa
il y avait bien entendu a entendu des
ravitaillements avec des gammes et le
dos on écoute l'une des organisatrices
on a des chiens craintif qui ont couru
et une fois qu'ils courent ils oublient
tout don qui sont à fond dans la course
et avec leurs maîtres
donc ça leur fait oublier leur peur donc
voilà c'est pour tout ça que
le sport avec un chien peut apporter
énormément alors il ya une fédération
des sports et loisirs canins qui
regroupe plus de 100 clubs en france et
il ya un club à coignières justement
genre vous qui posez la question alors
là qu'est ce qu'ils font sur ce thème
pour ou contre ce type d'événement bon
bah oui vous êtes pour où est sa maison
a pris que quelques horaires avec son
chien
vous avez des animaux dont je n'ai pas
non moi je fais pas partie je pensais
peut-être mais ça peut être ça pète bien
ça fait bien de corée avec les chiens il
faut suivre quand même quand les chèques
il faut prendre un chien saint jean oui
vous qui m'avez l'air passionnés par ce
bilan mais moi je vous raconte
l'anecdote mais ce que je raconte et or
aura t-elle mais oui c'est moi je suis
toujours pareil c'est toujours pareil
moi c'est du sport dans la mesure où
c'est du sport activité physique après
bon voilà allez on promène le toutou
fait une activité avec le chien est ce
qu'on croit pas ça nous a raconté qu un
minimum en somme on aurait un détail
peut-être parce que les téléspectateurs
ne comprennent pas non moi je me fais
prendre
non mais je vais amener un jour une
chienne promener en forêt et
elle n'a jamais voulu courir tout
simplement voilà c'est pas elle était
pas très obéissante
mais c'est tout c'était pas c'était pas
voilà mais sinon moi je dis bravo à ce
genre de compétition
cela dit j'ai deux chiens et on fait
souvent des balades baladou ou même
footing j'allais vraiment un petit un
petit teckel que j'emmène courrier qui
me fait l'honneur d'ailleurs de marcher
vite de ne pas courir quand je cours il
marche vite juste donc ça c'est assez
frustrant mais il ya au delà de au delà
de l'événement lui-même et de cette
activité sportive ou ce sport il y à il
ya un moment de communion avec les
propriétaires de chiens qui est vraiment
assez assez intéressant si en plus il ya
la partie la partie bonheur de pouvoir
courir avec des chiens à espérer et
quitte après à favoriser une adoption la
salle debout sur un adorateur donc là
ils ont ils ont je pense que c'est ça
l'intérêt ils sont ces hommes et ces
femmes ont tous gagné pour avoir encore
une fois fait régulièrement des séances
de ron de ou des grandes balades avec
les avec des chiens c'est des moments
assez privilégié pour qui et qui est
amateur de justement de cannes 1 et est
propriétaire de chien vous courrez 5 km
avec votre teckel un peu plus c'est à ça
c'est une sortie très longue mais saad
est arrivé de faire plus et d'ailleurs
sur une préparation marathon mais au
bout d'un certain moment d'ailleurs
c'était même trop long et mon chien
refusé de sortir avec moi donc c'est là
pour le coup c'était la saucisse les
tekken c'est la saucisse sur pattes
les japonais il est certes un juge
mais même l'intention d'y marcher vite
et il ne courait pas ce qui était très
frustrant mais ça m'est arrivé de faire
plus que 5e yann vous a pas entendu
cette activité non j'ai pas de chien
j'ai pas de chien j'ai pas de courir
donc problème était réglé
on va te faire du vélo mais pas de quoi
ouais enfin l'or va pas rentrer dans le
détail mais la course à pied trois
minutes sinon enfin c'est antinomique
par rapport à la pratique du du sprint
voilà c'est tout et
articulation et puis chez micropole
microtraumatismes et donc donc non par
contre toi je sais que il ya un
championnat de france qui qui existe sur
7 sur c'était sur ce sport là et là on
peut parler de sport est en effet il
faut que la la communion entre le chien
et l'athlète soit soit importante
un peu dans le même esprit que le cheval
avec son petit chien de traîneau si
souvent des moustiques cours mais voilà
si on peut pas les faire l'effet
reprenne au vu des gros chiens mais
dépêchez vous
enfin ce qui n'est pas un petit chien
non plus mais donc ça veut dire que le
coureur pour pouvoir donner enfin que le
chien donne de son de son de son
physique doit aussi galoper à une
certaine certaine allure donc en effet
compter qu'elle avec beaucoup de respect
pour toi mais il ya aussi la cas ni
trottinette aussi c'est à dire qu'elle
sonnait pour faire de la trottinette
avec son chien et du cani vélo justement
il y en a plus et des courses sur le
chien quand on voit toutes les femmes à
l'eau photo gw à la peur de possibles à
la non mais c'est vrai que ça
d'également le dogue allemand peut peut
emporter sap un certain goût porte toi
tu pourras pas monter dessus non plus le
dogue allemand
pourquoi pas certain certaines races qui
sont qui sont faites pour la course 2 on
va dire de pouvoir courir vite et
longtemps
ça dépend aussi du ce choix là pour un
mètre de d'emmener d'emmener tel ou tel
chien de courir ou se balader ou
également aussi les propriétaires aussi
à faire du sport chichi complètement ont
rejoint ont rejoint sûrement le coût du
goût de kanpe c'est tout prétexte est
bon le on le dit souvent ici à partir du
moment où il ya activité physique où il
ya dépense physique avec ou sans
dépassement de soi avec ou sans
performance bon ça c'est au moins bon
pour la santé
par contre ça va pas dans tous les sens
c'est à dire que c'est pas le chien qui
va faire que c'est pas fait d'avoir un
chien qui va vous faire que vous allez
courir c'est fait vous soyez coureurs et
que vous ayez un chat qui va faire vous
allez faire les deux en même temps parce
que quelqu'un qui est pas du tout du
tout sportif
s'ils sortent le chéquier débat il va
pas la fin c'est la fin de cette
émission va terminer par une citation de
l'ancien sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france aimé jacquet donner recevoir
partager ses vertus fondamentales du
sportives sont toutes les modes de
toutes les époques
elles sont le sport je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 70
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]